Ying show in China's southwest looks
nothing like it did before a magnitude 8
earthquake struck the town in 2008.
Julian Bing remembers crawling out from
underneath the rubble of his home he
survived but his sister did not nearly
15 years on he's been able to rebuild
his life and his business
I was in bastard for a while I didn't
want to work the first it took time
now I feel at home again the ink show
has changed so much the tongue has
advanced by decades including the
quality of buildings
with the earthquake hit on May 12 2008
rural towns in the epicenter were
completely flattened millions of people
were left homeless local governments
were accused of corruption and cutting
Corners during construction none of the
buildings in this town existed before
2008 except for this school its ruins
serve as a reminder of the sheer
destruction caused by that earthquake
and a memorial to the tens of thousands
who lost their lives
this sculpture marks the exact time the
earthquake hit thousands of schools
turned into Rubble many children were in
class that afternoon
kid Miyamoto was one of the first
foreign Engineers to survey the disaster
Zone
he also worked in Tokyo after the
earthquakes there last month he says
outdated and inadequate building
regulations were primarily to blame and
many countries say gold same thing same
stories essentially that the order of
concrete structures kill people
and uh no enforcement kill people
and we seems like learning the same
lesson over and over again
so that's the that's a sad part of it
after 2008 the Chinese government
updated building codes in this region to
include seismic strengthening yingsho
has been rebuilt to be Quake proof and
now boasts improved buildings and
Facilities as well as a new school
all schools and hospitals in winchuan
County are now reinforced to withstand
magnitude 9 earthquakes
many of those living in Yin Shaw say
they will never forget that day but they
have moved forward
After experiencing that earthquake your
whole mentality undergoes a complete
change you feel that life must continue
we must survive for many in his
community he says much was lost but in
the years since there have also been
gains
Katrina you Al Jazeera yingsho Town
wenchon County China